[Music]
Nataly famously took a shot at gender
and equality while announcing the best
director category at Sunday's Golden
Globes and here are the all male
nominees last night at the Critics
Choice Awards it was host Olivia Munn's
turn with niecy Nash to make a dig thank
you to the producers for paying me see
and I had the same amount of money and
Mark Wahlberg a million dollars the
sarcasm was a reference to a report that
Michelle Williams got less than one
percent after 1.5 million wahlberg was
paid for the reshoots on all the money
in the world who not have the money and
now comes a new report to that wahlberg
who had approval over which co-stars he
would work with refused to shoot with
christopher plummer unless he got the
hefty fee Williams reportedly was not
told of Marc's deal neither has
commented so far to show what willing to
walk away I can't the outrage was also
felt on the Critics Choice red carpet it
was shocking you know shocking how big
the difference was but for myself I have
never been paid the same as Romeo poster
the work and the profession are exactly
the same
ETS confirmed the Screen Actors Guild
did investigate the alleged pay gap and
found no contract violation I'm fighting
in him
it's hard to tell my kids about this my
two daughters they believe the world is
full of equality for them actually the
world's not quite fair for you
[Music]